Mass Effect Andromeda cinematic trailer
has landed but that's not the only
source of juicy new information on the
game I'm Tony and this game spot news
update is out of this world developer
Bioware has also released a fictional
orientation video for the Andromeda
initiative revealing more about the
game's story this initiative sends
explorers to the edge of the Andromeda
galaxy to find new planets to colonize
the journey puts the team in cryostasis
for 600 years but in terms of the
original trilogy the voyage begins after
mass effect 2 but before mass effect 3
in this way Andromeda avoids any
reference to the events of the third
game but Andromeda does borrow an
important mechanic from the previous
games loyalty missions they're back and
you can take on the side quests before
or after the main story is complete Mass
Effect Andromeda will release for ps4
xbox one and pc and spring 2017 a deluxe
edition is listed on amazon with some
extra outfits and weapons and the
soundtrack included Bioware has said
we'll see more gameplay at the game
awards this December but to keep up with
all the Mass Effect news in the meantime
you're already in the right place